look at the source of white light above
us you see these beautiful rainbow Halos
right but now look behind you at The Joe
Rogan Experience neon light you'll
basically just see the yellow you'll see
the orange that's because that's made of
gases that only emit light at very very
narrow wavelength or here's another
example wall this a laser spot oh yeah I
see a bunch of them you just see a bunch
of green dots yeah but now if I do this
here's a white light at that light you
see rainb right Isn't that cool that's
beautiful that's cool right that's
really pretty so this defraction grading
separates light out into all of its
different wavelengths it's called the
spectrometer now Isaac Newton and
William hersel figured out something
really cool they said if I believe if I
look at a light source like the sun if I
put a thermometer or like right here put
it where the red comes out over here it
starts to heat up the thermometer gets
warmer and they realize there's light
that you cannot see beyond the red
that's responsible for the perception of
heat that's called infrared radiation